what it do baby this week we bring him
out of the house with the fall of the
House of Usher by Edgar Allan Poe my man
it's a dull dark and soundless day up at
the House of Usher where our nameless
narrator just dropped in and see his
back win homeboy Roderick Usher
apparently all rightie been sick so he
said the narrator and letter basically
saying dear bro I feel like it man get
your ass over here and help a brother
out don't be a dick
now you think anybody would wanna chill
with his boy up in this mansion but his
crib is busted as hell even got a small
crack running from the roof to the flow
just looking at this fugly make the
narrator feel like he got an opium pango
word is that Roderick and his sister
Madeleine are the last surviving ashes
and he don't count anyway
the narrator rolls into the spot peep
game at Roger we can be like damn son
you looking way wider than usual
Roger say man I'm straight buggin you
know my sister Madeleine got some body
illness but this house is messing with
my mind making me all superstitious it's
this guard to lead a crib so the
narrator go into full-on bromo and start
painting and reading with him to get him
to stop moping around like a little old
[ __ ] but nothing can break Roddy from
that funk boy stopped flowing by the
king living large in a phat palace but
when some evil spirits start running up
on his crib run the damn place it go
from swanky to straight Jack
so Madeleine stopped moving and Rogers
like ah she did man
then fools started getting all paranoid
that a bunch of doctors gonna drop in
out of nowhere and start studying her
body for science yeah they will Roger
trip is so hard that he decide he gonna
stash her body in the fall but two weeks
before he moved her out of the house so
the narrator being a
well as homie there is houses boy carry
his sister's dead body and now her ass
in a coffin and secure behind an iron
door right before he do though and
believe Madeline's face and be like oh
this girl's smiling and she got rosy
cheeks I just don't look at her and keep
on keeping home over the next couple
days Rajic Minds slip little Moe and Moe
he always looking like he hearing noises
and an hour to start wondering if he
hiding something
oh we got that they stuffed her in the
coffin rowdy come busting through the
narrow at its door losing his over some
creepy glowing gas round the house the
narrator lifebuoy calm your ass down
that's just something that happens no
you gotta get this crazy-ass dude to
sleep there narrator cracks open a book
it starts reading about a hard-ass
Dragonslayer making a drag of his [ __ ]
crazy thing is though every time a sound
is described in the book riding a
narrator here that cold in the house
like on the night buses into the
dragon's lair they hear cracking and
ripping sound somewhere in the house
he'll eventually Roger completely break
down and start smiling and muttering to
himself like a real creep dude say even
hearing these noises for days and it's
Madeline who making them we must have
buried her alive man then all of a
sudden riding like break yourself fool
she had to go and sho'nuff there
Madeline is all bloodied up from bustin
out girl collapses on rock and they both
dropped in Raju from fear and her from
you know getting buried alive
the narrator like Oh time for me to get
my ass out of here and straight books as
he hauling ass away from the house he
looked back and watched a whole place
crumble to the ground
everybody in the hood know that my boy
like to keep it dark but more than any
other famous EAP jams I'll share perhaps
that's representing the Gothic style of
lit that define Poe's float I mean this
story got nasty whether a creepy haunted
mansion some mystery sickness hidden
bogs medieval decor and unearthing says
that some wack-ass thrillers been about
to go down you know what else makes my
nuts shrivel up twins
creepy man and apparently Pope feel me
on that one cuz they'd be doubling all
up in this text not only are Roger
gained his sister Madeline twins but
they both pale skinny as hell and
suffering from some shady ass illnesses
Rajic sick in the mind while Madeline
got that bump all in her body as the
story go on their roll star reversing at
first
Madeline wasting away all bed ridden
with no control over her life Roger got
to be the day a man of the house but
after they put her ass in the vault
Rogers start tweaking so hard he the one
who give up control even need one of his
brothers to read him a damn story so he
won't stone himself
Madeline though that girl ain't playing
she sets up and busts out of that coffin
even though it was nailed down and
sealed with an iron door this dead girl
got a superhuman will to live ain't
doesn't and as if that wasn't real
enough she's even associated with that
heart as Dragon Slayer in that story mad
twist while Madeline flexing her
strength by fighting her way out of the
stuffy ask often after being left in
there for a week
her brother rowdy the man of the house
turns into a whiny little [ __ ] now that
title got some twins going on - cuz it
got two meanings on one hand is talking
about the house that literally crumble
just hit by the end but on the other
hand it's referring to the usher family
bloodline cuz that variety of Madeline's
bodies get stacked there ain't no more
options on a family tree to carry on the
name what it feeling like it's only a
matter of time before your life and your
legacy gonna get [ __ ] it's hard not to
feel like you're trapped in a bunk ass
situation matter of fact the house is
crab
claustrophobic rules further them themes
of confinement isolation and loneliness
the windows were long narrow and pointed
and that's so vast the distance from the
black oaken floors as to be altogether
inaccessible from within feeble gleams
of in crimson light made their way
through the trellis objects around the
eye however struggled in vain to reach
the remoter angles of the chamber are
the recesses of the vaulted and fretted
ceiling dark draperies hung upon the
walls
I felt that I breathed an atmosphere of
sorrow an air of stern deep and
irredeemable gloom hung over and pervade
it all with the whole world closing in
around him Roger feeling mad alone so he
reached out to the narrator to help a
brother out
cuz when it's gonna hit the fan it's way
easier to cope when you got one of your
homeboys at your back the epigraph
reppin that same idea his heart is a
suspended loot as soon as it is touch it
resounds yo thanks for watchin man hey
y'all thanks for watching yo as always a
great way to support the show is by
supporting our sponsors and this video
is sponsored by audible all doable has
an incredible collection of audio books
original audio shows comedy news and
much more go to audible.com slash
Douglas to start a free 30-day trial and
when you sign up pick any book you want
download it for free and it's yours to
keep and that's forever man if you're
looking for a recommendation check out
the devil in the White City by Erik
Larson it's riveting true crime story
based on the sinister events that took
place in Chicago during the 1893 World's
Fair or check out the thug notes book
it's got detailed breakdowns on 16
literary classics and it's narrated by
me your main man Sparky sweets for more
about audible and to start your 30-day
free trial with a free audio book go to
audible.com slash Douglas to sign up and
we've got more great bad notes on the
way so click right here to check out our
channel page and be sure to subscribe
while you're there thanks for the
support and thanks for watching y'all
peace